Apple is saving up for something big.
With a cash stockpile of roughly 158 billion dollars,...
...a lot of people are wondering what Apple will do with all that money.
And today's Top 5, I'm counting down the five most disruptive yet plausible companies...
...that Apple could buy with their billions.
Starting off at number 5: Netflix.
Valued at around 26 billion dollars, Apple could scoop up Netflix...
...and still have plenty of money in the bank.
How about number 4?
Starbucks!
For around 57 billion dollars, Apple could own every street corner in America...
...and control access to one of our favorite legal drugs.
Back on more plausible ground at number 3: Tesla.
Heck, you could throw in Ford, too.
With combined value of under 100 billion dollars,...
...Apple could take the bad boy of automakers and the mom jeans of automakers...
...and create something as disruptive to cars as the iPhone was to smartphones.
At number 2: buy a carrier.
Big guns like AT&T and Verizon are just out of budget...
...so I propose Deutsch Telecom aka T. Mobile.
And now, my number 1 pick for the company Apple should acquire with their giant pile of cash: Comcast.
So, there you go.
Five companies Apple could easily snatch up with their billions.